[Music]
it's a beautiful neighborhood put an
awful block this is where Donald Trump
was born okay I don't need my own
biography Mike and there it is oh this
is it Mike
right I was born here and I lived here
till I was 4 years old so many memories
here the most important memory being
when I moved out of here so after my dad
made a ton more money evicting
minorities from their apartments which
was always a thrill we moved from the
hole I lived in to this pistol over here
okay every night I'd come home and I'd
go mom where's my snack where's my hat
is she supposed to make a snack for me
and she wouldn't I'd open the fridge and
I'd dump something out of the fridge and
throwing bottle on the floor to clean it
up that's what it's good for in every
glass all over her hand should be crying
so many great memories let's all change
this is not like the old neighborhood at
all
look at this hi honey photo and the
President of the United States I just
want to say I won't deport you because
you're so beautiful
you only give you a call later no my
wife's in DC I don't want me to have a
happy birthday or what but I also want
you to I want to have a happy birthday
and you're so beautiful we have a
special friend that you might remember
wait on the beard childhood did whoa
Paul Donnie
look at this guy oh wow I haven't seen
you in on a dog's a little wow you look
terrible I gotta say thank you for me
thank you
you do look great what happened here
what happened here I've had I've had one
marriage for 45 years arrabal yeah I
remember the school that you for school
we had a lot of fun anyway oh boy did we
ever yeah we played bumper chairs in
mrs. Smith's class and we pull on that
pony tail and we push him forward
distraction to somebody in front and
that's so funny but remember the bad
news was getting DTS news detention
everyone said DJ Donny Donny Trump
because I was the king of DJ you bet you
were didn't we used to eat oranges raw
oranges I would eat one and we would
just chop right into it through the peel
right through the peel as a matter of
fact I thought I bring a souvenir orange
label
happy birthday to me yeah well that is
disturbing look at that what's that up
check that out ooh yeah yeah oh yeah huh
oh yeah Paul great to see you
this couple worse I hate this
neighborhood this is really terrible
what are we off-roading there you go
wonder half ready here we go
surprise
you have your own whole booth here at
the diner around the corner boy or girl
it's a surprise party sir Mike a
surprise party is where you have
everybody here first and then you bring
me oh I was going to do when everybody
comes in they're surprised to see you
and you stay surprised when you get to
do it that's the reverse of a surprise
clock here's a gift I got for you this
that is my great grandfather's rifle oh
don't drop it
Oh nope don't drop it bring on the cake
my friend Emily Taylor Wow happy
birthday what's it huh this isn't
turning out how I wanted to sorry okay
well I know you feel you every like here
with us of course I hear you
their mop may be rumors look at you want
to my birthday gift lick it up not gonna
look it up look it up
like a dog
[Music]
you